[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think that was the intro for us Alan
Gilbert welcome to Copenhagen welcome to
the Royal Library in Copenhagen and
ladies and gentlemen here in in the hall
Alan Gilbert of course needs no
introduction
so I'll just say it's an honor to be
here with you it's a great pleasure to
be with one of the most outstanding
conductors in the world and at the same
time a quite charismatic cultural leader
of the world let's not go too far no
I'll keep it at that okay and also I'd
like to say welcome to everyone not here
in the Royal Library we have a lot of
viewers and listeners throughout the
country here in Denmark we also have at
many libraries among all of among other
places we also have Babar Tallinn with
us in Stockholm hello Bob al Holland and
even in Germany we have viewers and
listeners today so this is really a true
get together and we are here today
because of the Baltic Sea festival which
is seven days with classical music and
also seven conversations about music and
of course the theme of this festival
which is sustainability and this
actually is the first of these
conversations and interviews and this of
course there is of course also today a
concert and which is being shown here in
in this hall as well in a short while
which is a Britain Britain's Benjamin
Britten's huge work it was art which has
more and more than 250 contributing
musicians and that of course takes place
in valhallen and is broadcast as I said
in many many other places here in
Scandinavia and in Germany so we will
get back to the festival and the
festival theme about sustainability but
and I'd like to take a step back and
take a more general view upon classical
music as it looks today not least the
you could call it the never-ending task
of communicating and spreading classical
music to an ever-changing audience
you of course yourself have done a
tremendous amount of work towards that
to develop new audiences and so forth
but if you were to take a snapshot of
the classical music the field of
classical music as it looks today and
give me let's say three short headlines
how would that look what would those
three headlines be Wow yes I didn't you
didn't want to hear any of the questions
no no just don't make it easy I mean
that's it that's a that's a it's a huge
question and one that I deal with at
least indirectly all the time because
I'm trying to find my way and trying to
to think about how how I can do my job
as well as possible and what it actually
means to do my job and maybe it's that I
mean well I know I'm getting older but
maybe this is the reason that that I'm
thinking about the profession you know
wider way than I used to or at least I'm
trying to that is to say that when I was
younger I mean it is hard to do what we
do you know you're a pianist and and and
what we do as musicians is extremely
challenging and it can be enough just to
worry about being prepared for the next
concert and showing up on time and
making sure we have a clean shirt and
all these things that that that are part
of
sort of immediate and practical side of
the profession but I found myself more
and more thinking about why we do what
we do and what kind of impact it's
possible to have whether we can actually
in a direct way make the world a better
place
it seems very lofty and I feel almost
embarrassed to say that out loud but at
the end of the day I think that's what
we're doing and we've made a choice with
our lives to be musicians and it can
feel frustrating it can feel powerless
in a way because actually all we do is
play music and we are not solving the
climate crisis and we are not making the
political landscape more civil and we're
not we're not immediately curing cancer
many things that obviously would be nice
to see it happen but in some way if we
can use what we do as musicians and as
cultural figures and whatever platform
we have in whatever notoriety we have as
public figures to help people move in
the right direction then I guess that's
our priori a good thing I think that I'm
not the only I know I'm not the only
person and in fact I'm only a small
contributor in in a much wider movement
among musicians so I guess one of those
headlines you asking me about would be
social social engagement I think that
there are a lot of musicians who are
trying to use what we do as classical
musicians to make an impact to send the
right message
and I mean I'd like to ask you how to do
that because it we're all we're all
struggling we're all trying to figure
that out but I have seen that among many
of my colleagues and it's I think an
encouraging sign that it's it's not
enough simply to show up and play a
concert but but but it's possible
hopefully to use what we do as musicians
to to UM do good I think that's a little
bit what the Baltic Sea Festival is
about I think that you know it's
centered it's geographically centered
around the Baltic Sea but it's also
about the Baltic Sea and we know that we
know that along with the climate crisis
is a very immediate challenge to the
integrity of the oceans and the waters
around the world we see the Amazon
forest burning right now it's all
connected and sadly there are still many
people who are deniers of the fact of
climate change and maybe maybe by
putting a spotlight on this and saying
that we still stand for something that
we want things to get better and playing
concerts that are dedicated to this
notion maybe in some small way we can we
can make a difference that's the hope
anyway that's one of the headline lines
that's that's a very long headline yeah
headline was in there somewhere I hear
you saying something that I quite agree
with and that is that within the last
it's only about 10 or 20 years there's
become a higher level of consciousness
within the field of classical music as
to the world outside the classical music
world cannot necessarily be and looked
like the classical music world as it
looked like like 20 or 30 years ago
because there's a world outside and it's
not just knocking on the door it's
slamming on the door and and we see as
you mentioned yourself the climate
crisis is one of the major issues the
whole world needs to deal with right now
and in that sense the classical music
classical music can't just stand in a
bubble of its own
so compared to when I was an active
classical musician we didn't talk about
that at all not in any way and that's
not more than about 19 years ago I think
he used used the word bubble I think
there was a kind of bubble there was
this kind of sense of inevitability as
if as if nothing would ever go wrong
with the classical music world and
recordings were were rife and and there
seemed to be unlimited resources maybe
that's an exaggeration but certainly
there wasn't a sense of impending doom
or challenge to the to the field of
music that we see now I'm actually
generally speaking an optimist I don't
think that classical music is failing I
don't think that it's it's an in danger
of extinction some people say oh we have
to save classical music i I'm sure that
there if anything more people who are
enjoying classical music now than ever
before
but there's probably no reason no wrong
reason to turn our focus to to social
change but I have a feeling that the
feeling of people's feeling that they
needed to preserve the field of
classical music has led them to look at
other ways that they can sort of justify
themselves as classical musicians if you
look back upon what you have done
towards developing new audiences
reaching out to to the younger audience
as well and I mean this is something
that everyone within the field of
classical music is talking about more or
less every day how do we how do we
recruit new audiences what have you done
that you think went well that actually
that actually was a success and what
have you participated in which didn't go
that well well it's it's impossible to
know really the long-term impact of
anything you do you're right it's
something we talk about a lot and
and sometimes it can feel that talking
about it is all that ever happens how do
we actually do something that makes a
difference I think that this kind of
talk for example showing this side of
who we are as as people and as
performers is is one of the things we
can do to kind of demystify this
mythological presence that classical
music can have and the thing that makes
me almost more sad than anything is when
I hear people say oh classical music
that's not for me I don't think I would
understand it or I don't know I don't
have an outfit to wear to the concert I
don't have a tuxedo I mean the idea that
some people have about whether classical
music or any music for that matter is
for them is sometimes unnecessarily
narrow it's actually available and open
to everybody and more than anything I
think what we need to do to build the
audiences to make sure that people hear
that and they know that even without
preparation
even without training it's possible to
go to a concert or presentation of
costume use again immediately be seized
by it and there are I think a lot of
ways to do that it's possible to
experiment with the concert format so
that some of the traditional formality
of the concert concert ritual is is
broken down or eliminated altogether I
think you know you see what we should do
that casual Fridays or something like
that and they'll have a concert where
you're encouraged to come in sandals in
the short pants and a t-shirt or
something like that I mean that's
superficial but that's one thing you can
you can do I think it's also important
to show the connections between music
and other art forms other genres and
having having concerts that mix media
have jazz together on the same program
as a class before I mean there
I mean don't get me started I could go
on on and on about the different
possibilities but at the at the end of
the day I think it's about finding ways
to make what we do accessible
and-and-and grabbable and not not overly
epic so that it's so that it's
intimidating I've enjoyed doing projects
that that have combined drama and visual
arts and theater opera obviously is a
way to do to do that but in New York we
we did a number of presentations that
that were theatrical and changed the
concert hall into something that people
were not used to saying I mean a lot of
different possibilities within within
the last 100 years classical music has
also been a way to show which social
status you were in and and it even could
be looked upon as something which kept
us and them apart because often
classical music moving into the concert
halls in the beginning of the 20th
century was something you needed to pay
for it wasn't something that was out in
the open for everyone to hear and listen
and enjoy and I was at a concert in
London not that a long time ago and it
was they were playing it was the London
film and they were playing Tchaikovsky's
sixth symphony and after the third
movement there was this young man
sitting two rows behind me who was so
moved by the music that he of course
after the third movement which ends in
triumph he thought that the symphony was
done and he he stood up and began to
clap and he was I mean he must have been
a beginner I issue and he would but he
was so overwhelmed with the music with
the energy from the orchestra and the
whole you know the the music had really
taken I I'm terrified to hear where the
story's going I hope he was
censured and and that was the problem
because the next the Knicks are in a
tragic yes it was I was not that happy
either because the next minute of course
the the the the the police of the
audience were you know telling him to
sit down and he he was you know he was
really almost expelled from the audience
because he didn't know that that's there
in Chekhov's gives six Symphony is one
more movement and it doesn't end in
triumph it actually ends quite
differently but the thing was that they
really try to do and us and them that's
border and that's a painful and that's
all behavior and that's that's the music
and it's not even the concert hall or
the the concert situation as an
institution it's the audience yeah no
that's that's well I mean I think we can
agree that that's really really
unfortunate because if somebody is moved
by the music if someone shows the
priests appreciation what a great things
I mean and to have a natural response
that's what we're looking for and it's
how rare that is yeah that's really it's
criminal they just shouldn't have done
that I have a Tchaikovsky six-story as
well I was in in in school and I heard a
performance and a conductor a very
well-known conductor whose name I will
not mention right now turned around and
actually stopped the performance when
people clapped after the third movement
of the pathétique symphony and proceeded
to give a lecture explaining how the
symphony is a sacred form and should not
be interrupted and you have to allow the
architecture to exist in its purest
integrity and there was such nonsense
and and and you know it kind of served
the conductor right because then at the
end of the concert when the symphony
actually was over nobody did applause
was so
lukewarm yes because everybody was was
intimidated into not being able to
respond in a natural way
well let's hope that that doesn't happen
too often yeah I mean because there is
no wrong way to show appreciation I mean
in the age of Mozart you needed to clap
between they would repeat movements yes
they would clap while the music was and
they would split symphonies up they have
to do the first movement and then do
some other things some improvisation or
have a Aria and then they'd finish the
symphony later in the I mean it was just
this idea of I mean I agree Tchaikovsky
six that is an incredible arc and the nd
and the devastation you feel after that
false sense of victory that their
movement is is only possible if you've
here the last movement after having
lived through the first three yes but
it's so natural to to cheer after that
third movement but when I bring friends
who are unacquainted with the concert
situation within the field of classical
music and the the one thing they always
ask and they almost don't dare to do
anything is when do I clap yeah and I I
think the answer is when you feel like
you want to show your appreciation with
if the risk of the police well you know
it's nice it's nice sometimes I admit I
don't I don't mind when people don't
clap in in the middle of a symphony but
I also don't mind if they do clap and
the minimum is infinite so what so so I
mean it's impossible to give a single
answer to the question of how how would
we prefer it was because there is no
simple answer but I imagine that we we
don't necessarily want to go back to the
time of Mozart where and everything was
a almost party like circumstances when
why do you say that if everything was a
party would that be nice well maybe we
do
[Laughter]
anyway I understand what you mean it's
nice to have some sort of decorum and
and part of what makes the concert
special is that it is a special event
and you can you can show up in jeans in
the t-shirt in it and enjoy the concert
that I certainly do that myself but part
of what makes it special is that it is a
kind of sacred ritual and to feel that
you're going to experience something out
of the ordinary and okay I'm going to
dress up for this that also can add to
it so it's theirs but it's not necessary
for that to be the response and I I
think that people should be allowed to
experience concerts in the way they want
and that includes not disturbing the
experience for others so I think you
know if you start talking and you know
rattling your program and eating candy
during the music so that the people
around you are distracted that's one
thing but clapping after a movement I
think we should agree that that doesn't
cross the line into disturbing behavior
you said yourself right before that that
classical music has once in a while been
a clear declared towards the state of
extinction and let's face it classical
music has been pronounced almost dead or
predicted dead several times even 100
years ago when when their parents when
radio and the gramophone appeared and
and people could suddenly sit at home
listening instead of going to the
concert hall then Along Came
rock-and-roll music which was a punch in
the face not only towards classical
music but to the establishment of many
things and now nowadays we have the
Internet
it's not that many years ago that
Christian SEMA man interrupted himself
because someone was was filming his
concert from from the audience and he
said the the the the the negative
influence of the internet and YouTube is
is immense so many many villains many
predictions but classical music is
very much alive but how's the patient
doing in your in your opinion um I think
I mean I love trolling through YouTube
videos of concerts and and seeing
concerts on the Internet as much as
anybody I think there's nothing wrong
with that fortunately there's still
nothing that can completely replace the
experience of experiencing music life it
is very special to be in a room with a
group of people who are breathing the
same air and having the same emotional
even spiritual experience I think there
is something that I don't believe can be
duplicated and that's that's good
because it means that there's a reason
for live music to continue and there may
may be now more than ever because we can
sit on our screens more or less
experiencing the whole world anytime
anywhere
except but the sense of being in a room
and sensing something which is now and
only now is is incredibly beautiful and
yeah and I agree more than ever because
it's so common for people to experience
life through the filter of a screen but
you know I just it's apropos of nothing
but I was just reminded of an experience
I was talking to a group of conducting
students in in Shanghai and classical
music is flourishing in China it's
unbelievable how many musicians there
are and and one of the things that they
were students were asking is how do I
learn about the traditions of
performance how do i how do I experience
concerts and and performers that who
don't come to China and I said well you
can watch youtube videos and they all
kind of looked it sheepishly around
because they're not supposed to mmm
watch what YouTube is not supposed to be
there but they have VPNs and it's
possible to do it and so I kind of
winked at them and I said well you know
you can look at this and I gave them
some names that I thought they could
listen I could see them writing it down
and of course they don't they don't
actually look at YouTube but I'm hoping
that they were able to somehow
experience this and it's great that that
can happen because now you know you know
I think in a good sense the world is
getting smaller because of the internet
there are many positive and incredibly
strong educational possibilities that
can happen just because of the access
but you know that's something that that
you know we talk about all the time both
in the concert hall but also at home as
parents you know with the kids who are
on phones all the time you know to
actually you see that also at concerts
yes people go to their kids concerts and
they don't look at what's on the stage
they're holding up their phone to get
all the thing and inside just you know
just look at the concert listen yeah
this what's happening in front of your
face but yeah that's another story
no that's not you guys I think they're
in the varible Hall in Washington now
they're probably cringing and covering
their faces well I'd like to move on to
to Colin Wilson because we agreed on
talking just a bit about Colin Olsson
being in Copenhagen but but I just like
to end this this first chapter off
because you said that within the last I
think you said ten years or maybe even
twenty years that you've been more and
more searching for a why as to why do we
keep on playing why do you and many
other fantastic musicians keep on
playing this fantastic music which in
many cases is 100 or 300 years old and
and have you are still searching have
you are you getting closer to some kind
of definition as to what it is classical
music actually can give citizens of the
world in this digital era we are living
in I know it's a huge question but I
mean no I mean I
no I don't feel like as if I'm any
closer to the answer it's a little bit
as if you know the world is expanding
and the more you if the if this sphere
is your knowledge the surface area that
is touching the unknown is bigger and
bigger as you as the knowledge it
expands I it's not only the why of music
because I think you know I'm in the
middle of rehearsing Mateos pacion to do
next week with the Swedish radio choir
and orchestra and and there are moments
where I'll be sitting looking at my
score that are really just with the
score open and not listening or anything
just looking at the music and I can feel
a tear coming into my eye just because
there's something so stunning and when I
rehearse the unbelievable Swedish radio
choir last week it's a piece they've
done many times and and we're all
familiar with the music and and I could
see there were suddenly moments where
people were just almost overwhelmed by
by the music and that that can still
happen today I think is inspiring and
that's certainly reason enough I think
to pursue it but more than the why or
the kind of existential why of behind
there are choice to do music I think
using it's it's related to the to the
social engagement that I briefly touched
on earlier why do we do performances is
it possible to create a bigger meaning
to the performance in the way that the
Baltic Sea Festival is about
sustainability or in the way that yo-yo
ma is using his Bach project to play all
the six Bach Suites not just not just
for many people but in specific
geographical locations where a message
of shared humanity is necessary and
you know he went down to the border of
Mexico and Texas to play there and he
wants to play at the 38th parallel and
he wants to go to the west bank and and
and that kind of why also yes what we as
musicians can do to make human social
and even political statements mm-hmm
let's move on to to come Wilson one of
the great Nordic composers and we are in
Copenhagen so let's talk about a danish
composer
which well i think you could say he's
one of the most well known composers
from scandinavia together with greek and
sibelius probably you would say and
we're sitting here at the Royal Library
which stores an impressive amount of
original Carlsen material scores chamber
music piano music Symphony scores and so
forth also a lot of his letters are
being preserved here I'm so eager to go
look I haven't this is my first time
setting foot in this building and I
haven't had the chance to to explore but
I think you need chocolate love's
I'll get yeah I'll get to that hopefully
and it's very appropriate to talk about
Collison because you obviously did a
huge effort together among other places
with the the New York Philharmonic
towards Nielsen's music so tell a bit
about why you picked up on Nilsson and
and and what you found
Nilsson is a composer I came to
relatively late and it was through
performances at the New York
Philharmonic my parents as some of you
may know were violinists in the New York
Philharmonic so I grew up in New York
around this Orchestra so I heard many
many concerts and rehearsals by the
orchestra and I will never forget one
performance it was with Herbert bloom
stead conducting the Fourth Symphony the
inextinguishable this and
it must have been the first time I heard
it because it hit me like like a ton of
bricks
it just completely knocked me out and I
couldn't believe what I was hearing it
was really unlike anything I had ever
heard before and and and and it was
thrilling and what was it that was so
thrilling compared to what you've hired
no it just it was just from moment to
moment it just didn't let go and and you
know of course in the end is you know
with the battle and it's just it's it's
an amazing amazing piece and and that
kind of sat in the back of my
consciousness for a while and I I didn't
do a Neilsen symphony myself for years
after that I didn't hear very much
Nielsen after that I later learned that
Leonard Bernstein one of my predecessors
at the New York Philharmonic was a huge
Nielsen lover and champion and did a few
of the symphonies but not all of them
and I'm here as well and did them here
as well local Orchestra yeah and I went
to I went to Stockholm to be the chief
conductor of the Royal Philharmonic the
Royal Stockholm Philharmonic and it
happened that some of you may know the
name mats angstrom who was our artistic
administrator at the time is a Nielsen
fanatic completely crazy about Nielsen
and and and he you know he's Swedish but
I think he felt a real kind of ownership
and and a proprietary love of the music
and he made sure that I got to know all
the symphonies and I started to perform
them in program them in Stockholm and
one of the things that I decided to do
when I got to New York was then to do a
exploration a traversal of all the
symphonies and it happened that that the
record company that Copple was
interested to take take the performances
for four CD recordings and it's it's
been fascinating to me because
it's there was a there were a few years
where we did tons of Nielsen in New York
and people seem to really like it and
and there was always a strong response
but it's a little bit as if the the and
I hate to say this because I think it's
really too bad but it's as if somehow
whatever ripple we created by throwing
the pebble in the water has kind of
calmed and I don't see a lot of people
playing Nielsen these days and I'm not
sure why that is
Sibelius you see a lot people compare
the two symphonies I think kind of for
the reason that they're Scandinavia and
that's the only reason I can think of
because there's no didn't see more
different in fact yeah that's on and
equally valid and equally great and
equally accessible you know there's
nothing about Nielsen I think I mean
he's quirky and unusual and strange and
and and some of his especially the later
seventies good and get bizarre but in a
kind of wonderfully human way
there's nothing about his music I think
it's difficult to grasp I'm not quite
sure why it's why it hasn't totally
caught on around the world but I'll
continue doing what I can because I
totally believe in the music I think
it's incredible and very personal and
you know has all the hallmarks of great
music it really is great music I think I
mean somewhat sometimes you hear people
talking about a kind of Nordic sound and
they actually do compare Nilsson with
Sibelius and not really Greek but but
still there is in my opinion very few
there are very few similarities between
the two of them and I cannot really hear
maybe it's like we talked about before
it's we talk between about the
difference between Copenhagen Stockholm
I can't see what Copenhagen is I cannot
I can hear Karl Milson but it's
difficult to me to actually point out
because I've grown up with him I've even
recorded him in this very room that's a
call that's very
and and I've listened my grandfather who
was a composer and musician played
calendars my whole life I it's almost
like you know a chair you've seen since
you were seven years old standing in you
in your home you can't see it anymore so
I could for menials in his Nielsen it
would be really sad if we actually could
in very convincing terms describe what
made a composer yes that composer yes
it's impossible to do and that's why we
have the music yeah Nielsen is really
unique and and for me spiritually and
emotionally completely different from
Sibelius I love Sibelius as well but I
they're not they're not cut from the
same cloth at all and I'm not sure what
it is that makes me else an instantly
recognizable there's Nielsen but there
is something there and it's it doesn't
sound like so many others no you can say
that's very much from the dramatic
symphonic tradition you can absolutely
hear they're they're they're elements of
his his orchestral sound that even you
can compare to to Elgar and and and and
other 19th century romantic composers
but there's nobody like him hmm
[Music]
let's move on to the focus of this
festival as we mentioned earlier this
festival does have great focus on
sustainability and I'd like to hear and
what what are your thoughts on this this
is a music festival with with focus on
sustainability do you really believe
that a festival and then the message
like this can can change the minds of
people in a way it's a bit of a paradox
isn't it because flying across the globe
is very much a part of the classical
music industry you need to transport
conductors and soloists and and at times
even 100 people in an orchestra from
city to city so it's it's not that
sustainable is it oh it's a it's a kind
of I don't think it's
too far to go to say that it's a kind of
existential crisis for musicians because
as you say almost by definition in order
to do what we do in the places that we
do them we have to get there and very
often it's by playing I took the train
here this morning by the way from
Stockholm that was the first thing you
told me no but we were talking about
about about sustainability and it's you
know it's a small gesture but I think
you know they say that they say that the
meat industry is actually as bad if not
worse than the aviation industry for the
climate and one thing that I think is
heartening is that if everybody ate a
little bit less meat hmm
that would make a big difference and
similarly if everybody flies a little
bit less by definition it will help it's
not the answer it's not the end of the
story but I think we are at a point
where people have to take personal
responsibility to do what they can
individually to help the situation
beyond that we're even at a probably a
more more crucial inflection point in
the whole story of climate change and
climate crisis because there is only so
much that individual people can do and
it's going to have to become a matter of
public policy and politicians are gonna
have to do something because there's
only so much we can do no matter how
little meat we eat or how how rarely we
fly again as I said we're musicians what
can we do
I'm trying and I would love your help
and I'm happy to kind of
publicly announced this hope that I have
is to create a a an alliance of
classical musicians performers soloists
conductors who travel a lot who agree to
do something it's deliberately vague I
don't know what the right thing is but
if we all agree to try whenever possible
not to fly to try whenever possible to
do whatever we can to aid sustainability
to commit a percentage of our fees to
the right object of of carbon neutrality
it's a very complicated subject I've
been doing research about it and there's
not a lot of agreement about what the
best thing to do is people say oh plant
trees and then people say oh that's not
good because then you have to make sure
that the trees 10 years from now are
taken care of I would say that we're
going to do something we're going to try
to do something and even if it's not
perfect I think a priori doing something
and trying to do something is better
than not so Russell Marcus trees who are
taking some quite radical measures as to
you know being kind of almost the event
guard of trying to reduce co2 imprint
orchestras who are not transporting any
of their conductors and soloists by
plane is that too radical do you think I
think practically speaking it would be
very difficult for certain orchestras
continue to continue to exist as the
kinds of organizations they are if they
did that I feel horrible saying it
because I think it'd be nice if we could
do that but if if if the New York
Philharmonic wants to engage a conductor
from Europe I would you can really spend
three nights on the Atlantic Ocean yeah
I mean I would I would say that there is
a certain
balancing that you have to do they're
kind of artistic demands and artistic
exigencies that should be considered
selfishly I would like to be able to
continue to conduct orchestras thing in
the United States it would be very
difficult to do if I just said I'm not
going to fly anymore but I'm thinking
about it
mmm it sounds really pathetic but at
least we're thinking about it I would
say because that's it wasn't even a
subject I remember talking to a
conducting colleague of mine must have
been 30 years ago and he was bragging
about how many flights he had taken and
and I thought it was so cool you know
wow he's really you know active he's
he's got a career he's flying all over
the place and now I think the you know
this is a radical kind of flying shame
you know that whole shame of flying
thing that's I know it's a little bit I
think drastic but I think we all feel in
a little bit now that there's a sense ok
we should we should try to moderate our
our tendencies just to think ok we can
just jump on a plane and go anywhere
I know orchestras that certainly now I'm
starting in Humber got the
Elbphilharmonie Orchestra a couple weeks
actually as the chief conductor and we
were just just last week having a
discussion about touring and whether
it's important to tour you know why why
bring an orchestra for example to I mean
I conduct in Japan regularly Japan has
many wonderful orchestras do they really
need to have this constant parade of
international orchestras of who are
coming to play when they already have
many orchestras they're in some artistic
sense I would say yes but I wouldn't
have even asked this question 25 years
ago now I wonder is it really necessary
we have to really justify why do we do
it I think for orchestras themselves
touring is a very positive thing it's
really the kind of
and the special circumstance that goes
around the tour really does lead very
often to artistic growth and that's a
nice thing for the orchestra and without
without the without the impulse of
having to tour
you don't necessarily achieve that kind
of artistic growth in the same way I'm
not saying it's impossible I like being
able to show where the orchestra's I
conduct but I think we really have to
question why we do it and to what extent
it's necessary I mean just think about
the carbon footprint or the impact of
transporting it's often more than a
hundred musicians for their staff and
the instruments and it's it's it's
dramatic yeah I don't know what the
answer is it is uh it's it's it's a very
huge issue and I think it's you might
say that at least there is some progress
to be seen for instance in the festival
like this that you actually have this
focus of a festival and to me that is a
huge step as compared to 10 or 20 years
ago where festivals were more festivals
in for the for their own sake and not so
much to to convey a message to the
audience and in that way I mean things
are happening and and things need to be
happening as of now because as we know
if we don't do something quite soon
we'll have a true crisis not only the
the the situation we have now but by the
far more seriously now yeah I mean it's
I mean the science is clear it's not
idle speculation we know that if we
don't do something so now we're yes you
know
in deep [ __ ] okay and quiet in two
minutes actually we we are saying
goodbye to a Babbitt Helen next Saturday
you will be conducting one of the true
Giants of music history you want
Sebastian back as you told us it will be
his sing Matthew Passion and that will
be in da ville' column that we are
saying goodbye to in just a moment but
before that I'd like to for you to ask a
question that we can pass on to
tomorrow's talk which is not another
parallel howling but is in Riga and it's
a talk like one we've had here today and
it will be the prelude to the Rheingold
according to ASA paka paka salonen as
the concert is called so do you have a
question that we could pass on for
tomorrow well at they were just where we
are in the conversation here leads me to
ask because I understand that it's not
musicians who are having the
conversation but more public figures and
maybe from the political side how do you
see the nexus of politics and culture in
terms of of solving the the problems are
trying to address the issues that are
facing the planet are there ways that
people from the cultural world musicians
can use their public platform to help
efforts and to what extent is supporting
the arts actually self serving in terms
of the political need to to affect
change
this is hereby passed on to talk over to
the station tomorrow it's quarter to
5:00 so we'll just have a very short
break here in Copenhagen and we'll keep
on talking a bit with questions from the
audience and the question by SMS and
email from from the rest of Denmark and
Sweden as well but as of now we'll say
goodbye to Bob of Holland and thank you
a lot thank you
Thanks oh my god well iPad and iPad ah
there you are so I think the 20 seconds
that I promised to stop have gone and I
have an iPad handed over to me which
will hopefully very soon be full of
questions but we also of course have an
audience here and I think we have a
portable microphone so why not start
here I'm sure that someone in the
audience is dying to ask a question to
mr. Allen Gilman or mr. Koppel here
maybe on the topic of sustainability
which is of course if quite huge topic
but nevertheless the focus of the
festival don't all speak at once
well let's see what happens on the email
[Music]
in a while and in the meanwhile I could
ask you if you could say a bit about how
is the I mean you've been in the US for
so many years as the principal conductor
of the New York Philharmonic how is a
now you you've living in Stockholm and
soon you'll be beginning in Hamburg what
is the difference between the the the
climate the circumstances which the
classical music is living within in the
u.s. compared to the to Europe you're
talking about the non controversial kind
of climate now right yes the atmosphere
the the yes the feeling yes well well
for instance the short answer is that
there's there's no describable
difference I mean people are people and
and and what we do is essentially the
same I'm the same person whether I
perform in New York or Cleveland or
Berlin or or Copenhagen and so I present
myself to the audience in the same way
and more or less people respond in a
similar way
audiences are different tastes are
different expectations of repertoire are
different but these are kind of I will
call them lo great differences
fundamentally it's all the same that
having been said naturally the the the
culture and the expectation the climates
surrounding the concert life in
different places it's different
obviously
I'm having to for example get to know
Homburg in a new way up and conducting
there for 18 years I think that the
first time I conducted was back in 2001
and even so
as chief conductor I have to find the
best way to interact with the audience
to speak to them to make a connection
but that equation is I think it's
unknown even to the people who have been
there all along because of the Newhall
the incredible new Elbphilharmonie which
has changed the landscape there I guess
I said the best way and I think the
there is no best way and there's
certainly no right way it's about
building up a trust and and making a
connection with the audience and I think
it you know just as people are different
and people from you know we were talking
about the differences of people from
different backgrounds different cultures
backstage and you know again luckily
just as it's impossible to describe
Nielsen it's impossible and maybe not
even desirable to try to pin down how
you would describe people but that's
that's what audiences are they are
people and there is a kind of aggregate
of the of the collective consciousness
and and I guess finding the right way to
read it and hopefully being yourself
while you're doing that is is what we
try to do it's not an answer to your
question but it's kind of an amusing on
that and then the subject around that
question is is the Europeans European
audiences are they more sophisticated
than the American or is that just a
prejudice way of seeing it well I mean I
would never I know I would say I don't
think you can say that because how can
you talk about the European audience
when when it's you know it's like saying
all you know all Danes are this this way
you know what do they do believing
ridiculous and and not to mention
offensive but but in terms of
programming for instance no I would not
say that no but it really depends where
you are it also depends within a city
what the what the what the expectation
is for example in New York New York is a
big place there's no one you are
audience audience and we we often
commented that when we played in Lincoln
Center there was one feeling in the hall
and then when we played in Carnegie Hall
which is a different very close just 10
minute walk it's a completely completely
different feeling in the hall and there
must be some overlap of audience but
even within New York City there's a very
different feeling into those two
audiences and then if you go across the
park to the 92nd Street Y which has a
very distinguished concert series
another feeling altogether again and
then downtown at the at the Poisson
Rouge or different different venues that
that present concerts different again so
I think it's wrong and dangerous not to
mention impossible to generalize that
that way people very often ask me oh how
would you compare American orchestras as
compared to German orchestras mmm it's a
meaningless question in a way because
they're you know there's so many
different orchestras and and you know
the Berlin Philharmonic is not the same
as the virus your own home but still
there are some some some quite important
differences as to funding and does that
in any way I mean the private funding
being so much part of how classical
music continues to survive in the u.s.
compared to Europe I've just I've just
spoken against generalizing but I'm
going to generalize here I I think that
the trend is very much the same both in
the states in the States and in Europe I
think America is maybe a little bit
farther down the path towards fully
private funding Europe doesn't have the
same culture of
needing to have private funding because
still it's true that the government's
and the the public funding are or more
supportive of the arts I would say
generally although it's senders are
going down yes and so you know I
remember when I was in in Stockholm I
kind of expected when I started there
that fundraising would be part of my my
job there because that's very much part
of what a music director in the state's
I hadn't been a music director in the
States at that point but I knew that and
it really wasn't wasn't the case because
they were there's there's very little
sort of socializing in order to to
cultivate sponsors and there's also not
yet the the legislation that makes it
easy for people to be philanthropic to
cultural organizations there they're not
the tax benefits that that that exists
in the United States so there's gonna
have to be a legislative change in
Europe before that starts to be more
than norm but I think it's going in that
direction because I think governments
are tending to to cut arts funding which
is unfortunate but probably a reality
mm-hmm
how about contemporary music still no
differences as to how adventurous and
how much we are able to keep that heart
of hands on the situation I think that's
very local and I'm I actually you know
people have said that I'm a strong
advocate of contemporary music which I
hope I am but I but I also don't think
of myself that way at all I don't think
of myself as a specialist and I kind of
resist the categorization of music into
sort of classical music and contemporary
music as if somehow there's something
special or separate
or removed about what's happening in
contemporary music because it's all
music it's all part of one continuum and
I think that actually it can turn around
the backfire if you make too much of a
point of the sort of specialization in
contemporary music because it does treat
it as something that needs special
treatment but still it's the fact that
it is very music is people are people
are afraid of what they don't know so
these so the thing to do is make sure
that they know what what it is and that
can mean including contemporary music on
on on other programs to force them to
listen to it if you will it's not really
how I like to think about it but if they
you know they might come to the
Beethoven symphony but you actually make
them listen to something else as well
but not just for a token reason you
don't choose something just to sort of
force-feed this sort of bitter tasting
medicine down their throat it's
important to have a real reason to to
play anything that you program and and
very often I will speak in a concert to
discuss what it is about the new piece
that I like because Beethoven symphonies
don't necessarily they can use it
sometimes but they don't necessarily
need an introduction but a totally brand
new piece that's in a unfamiliar
language may be helped by a sort of
opening the door so people are not
totally shocked and overwhelmed when
they hear it for the first time that's
the thing if you if you think about
contemporary music you're hearing
something very often that is in a new
language if you go back to the time of
Mozart even a new symphony people had
more or less an idea of what the
language was going to be but today it's
it's a free-for-all there are composers
who who might write one note that just
lasts for a long time where you might
have something that's so packed with
instruments and information that is just
completely overwhelming kaleidoscopic
glittery moment or you'll have something
that's repetitive or you'll have
something that's very lush and romantic
and full of traditional sounding
harmonies you never know what to expect
if you're hearing a new piece so part of
the challenge of new music today is just
not knowing what language you're gonna
have to be translating and listening to
so it can be useful to play examples or
maybe even play a piece twice about the
second time they hear it is it's it's
more familiar I think it's important not
to not to forget that it's still music
though and that they're just because
there are no rules and and things are
not necessarily all in the same style
that doesn't mean that they that you
can't get into it right away but you
have to open the door sometimes it's
enough just to say you know what I
really like this piece it's about five
minutes long and you'll hear three
minutes into the piece there's this
instrument back there that plays in it
he only plays one note just watch for
that and that's enough to make people
listen with open ears it's not a
brilliant thing to say but just almost
anything can sort of break down the
barrier that lets people in hmm
if we could if we could look into the
future look into the the Meuse music
world of like 100 years from now 200
years oh man hopefully there is a world
let's insist on assuming there's a world
yes how do you think the the the
classical music world of what would it
be
2120 would look or even 20 to 20 and and
what music is class will they be
listening to the contemporary music
story of our time as classical music in
a hundred years from now I think some
things yes yeah I think some things it's
impossible to know because obviously
it's impossible to know but if you look
back to you know Beethoven famously did
his so-called Academy concert in which
he presented the world premiers of the
Symphony the sixth symphony the fourth
piano concerto the Masen see up had to
see dope this was a contemporary music
concert remember and all of these pieces
were being choral fantasy all being
heard for the first time yep
I don't know if people thought or if
even it was an important question then
you know will this music endure must
have been an interesting experience yeah
I mean my guess is that they probably
didn't know and they probably wouldn't
even enter their minds to worry about
such a thing
but I have a feeling that Beethoven will
endure and I'm sure there are others but
think of all the composers that didn't
that haven't remained current from that
time yes so we know Beethoven we know
Mozart we know Bach obviously they've
survived but they were hundreds if not
thousands of other composers who are
lost to history yes there are many you
know the that's that's the other thing
with with so-called contemporary music
now to have the expectation that every
piece you hear is going to be an a
lasting masterpiece and is unrealistic
it's just a question of percentages
there are a lot of pieces that's had to
say will probably never last and never
be heard heard of after you know after
they're played for what the first time
but maybe there will be some pieces that
that will last I mean if I listen to I
know the first thing that came into my
mind I'd you know luigi's look around my
car from which I just did recently I
have a feeling that that is the kind of
music that will last or John Adams
harmony there these are pieces that I
think are classics and it will remain
but of course it's impossible to say
well I think time has run out for us
it's a it's five o'clock the concert
will commence in just a few moments so
it's been a huge pleasure to meet you
and they have this conversation so
thanks so much and good luck next
Saturday thank you and what a pleasure
thank you much and thank you thank you
all for being here today
[Applause]